[Music]
i i think it's something that people
more and more really thirst for just
having
honest conversation that is not
encumbered by the the usual convent
conventions of broadcast media i mean
the absurd
time limits where you see on cnn for
instance where they're
they're attempting to talk about
something of
civilizational importance and you see
you know some world expert on whatever
it is climate change or the
you know threat of war between the us
and china or
you know whatever the moment is that
needs to be talked about you see
such a person given six minutes
to say something of value before they
cut to a commercial
it's just an insane way to try to make
sense of
of what's going on in the world and and
people have become
increasingly sensitized to that it's
just that there's something
especially when you're looking at when
you talk about controversial issues
where people have um you know where it
has more the character of a debate
right well then people come to these the
usual
uh formats with you know their their
canned
talking points and you know they're just
desperately trying to get out some
you know pre-prepared paragraphs which
you know you you know under threat of
interruption and
there's no possibility of of good faith
dialogue right there's
the idea that anyone's mind is going to
change
by virtue of what happens in that
conversation is i mean that's just
there's not even the pretense that
that's possible right so it's it's a
it's not in truth it's not actually a
dialogue
you're asked to witness parallel
monologues or serial monologues
uh so people are i think right to be
dissatisfied with that and
and the you know podcasting is
on some level it's it's exactly like
radio i mean it's essentially radio on
demand
but it's different in
at least two crucial respects one is
that you know most podcasts
some some function differently i don't
know how yours
functions i don't know if you have if
you impose a strict time limit on
yourself but
you know many podcasts certainly mine
don't have any
notion of a of how long a podcast should
last right so some of my podcasts are
an hour you know or you know or summer
i think the longest has been close to
four hours right and it's entirely
dictated by
just the dynamics of the conversation
and the needs of the moment
and to not having
the the burden of a ticking clock or a
or a
production a schedule that you have to
slot into
really does change things even when the
final conversation winds up being
more or less just as long as a radio
conversation would have been
right so if you so like knowing that you
only have an hour
is different than just having a
conversation that
that only lasts an hour and it's it's
different all the way through i mean
literally every moment is different
in my experience as both as a host and
as a
as a participant because it because when
you have no time limit
being interrupted is not a threat to you
ultimately saying what you need to say
so you have the freedom
to digress and let the other person
digress you have the freedom to let the
other person
attribute views to you that you don't
hold because you know that you have the
time to
clean up the mess the conversation can
breathe in a way that
it never can in normal formats on
television
and even on ra even long-form radio so
it's unusual in that respect i think
people
appreciate the difference the the other
big difference for certain podcasts
my own in particular is that
the business model is different and
podcasts are are far less vulnerable to
the pressures you know many legacy media
outlets feel to um you know public
changes in public sentiment
right so the idea that you're going to
come under pressure and and get canceled
for something you said or speculated
about or or didn't make clear or
it's far less fraught it's not to say
that you you can't
you know stir up controversy
inadvertently or otherwise but
it's it's a far better defended medium
in terms of
being able to to think out loud without
having to be worried that
you know you're going to pay a an
unrecoverable penalty for it